hello and welcome to this video is off
probably not the right way to pronounce
it okay
he goes for a double V on keto
interesting see going for d5 setup or or
more of them more of Hippo okay and I'm
a little bit concerned about blacks
timing here so what's going on I can't
even go h5 right there is no pressure
here on my center
let's go h5
so night takes on Bishop tanks I feel
that my bishop is not so useful here
with his pawns there on g6 doesn't feel
very useful so how does he play this now
I mean I can cancel
I can Castle queenside Bishop g5 if he
has to go f6 that is damn ugly really
ugly but Queen d2 is also just going to
be fine just Castle long
he wants to go to f6 I cannot really
that's not really a great idea
I can let's do this I mean he has to go
f6 then I know I had could have done
that before it still f6 and then Bishop
f4 that maybe he's got g5 or something
yeah probably I should have just
castlelong
tough too tough to decide what why is
that a move after g4 okay why is that a
move
I mean 96 has to has to replay almost YF
o f6 know f6 probably just Bishop a form
96 if I take pawn takes Bishop h6
yeah but I'm threatening too much I
cannot take everyone C form that's not
pre move him cannot take on c4 that's
just not on Quincy 6 no official g7
hmm it's tough to believe that black can
survive him yeah I didn't I didn't see
an instant mate that is absolutely true
[Music]
here with this chick King f6 Queen h4
[Music]
it's kind of unbelievable
[Music]
yes don't see you when it's really
really frustrating and this this cannot
that's not a reputation I mean fantastic
Queen d5 what else
what is he just taking a to like really
really trying to rub it in yeah like you
can do everything here and not get
checkmated
yeah 95 is my gym not that is still far
from comfortable with this position from
liquid okay come on a quick move and
just time yeah I know that again so how
can you not just checkmate them so this
this this whole way of playing looks
very dubious then what gets an attack
very quickly so h5 takes Bishop takes oh
and the engine is always easy for the
computer I just like white wins plus two
point something but you still have to do
it so takes takes and now yeah that's
that's really not so clear to me
Knight fg4 that makes sense them but
Queen d2 also gets a very high
evaluation 97 and Bishop g5 so I'm not I
haven't spoiled anything but it's
amazing to me that somehow here it still
is get somewhat interesting yeah I
probably g4 is not the right move then
you just Castle Castle queenside yeah
this is this is not this is not winning
it's just not wins it doesn't win it
doesn't win which is amazing Bishop h6
Queen C form so instead just like get
everything into play and win win
conveniently I'd say I mean this attack
is white wins automatically on the key
on the King side if there isn't
something drastic happening on the other
side because you cannot defend against
something like g4 Bishop h6 and so on I
just thought it's time to strike already
but this is just still I'm still a game
Knight c3 is better he'll see
I only hear realized that there is this
counter play on c4 and the engine at
least at this depth doesn't see anything
just says I should make a draw amazing
yeah Queen f1 I didn't want to make a
draw I mean it kind of felt to me that I
may be after it yeah this is not correct
and now black should win it took a very
long time here for something like 25
Queen before seems to be better
interesting and the engine 0.4 mad you
know this is something it's on depth 19
and after there's something way a little
bit of additional depth can make all the
difference between black being better
defending or being worse I think all
evaluations are possible so if I've was
the right move and then after Queen g5
play King e6 that's very simple for you
oh my god and it gives zero at this dis
calculation depth okay here 95 f5 looks
several it's actually the best move I
mean it looks kind of like the obvious
choice but it's still not sure not sure
of course yeah it's I didn't didn't play
it where I am I should somehow spot that
96 is still still somehow a defense okay
the engine also mentions that I can do
this but it really makes no sense to go
into this kind of thing if you can just
Castle queenside instead I mean here
there is just no counter play at all for
black okay guys thanks for watching